Hey, what's going on? Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday, March 18 2000.
I take what's going on?
No,
no.
What's up with you? What are you say? Um,
I am uh, you know, I realized this
morning when I was washing the dishes,
I just come from the gym by Dubai, don't
do it. And then I did my upper body.
I actually ran into somebody this
past weekend. They'll say, dude,
I always see at the gym that was,
he's like, you're always doing legs.
That made me feel good. You
know, being a child of the 80s,
you never did. Your legs was just
all about the upper body, right?
Just building yourself up from the
waist up like a house of fucking cards.
And all it took was one leg sweep.
One for Dota and putting up fucking three
15, four times, dude. One leg sleep.
What damage land on your side.
Separate your shoulder.
Right?
Just covering up the skinny little legs,
trying to fucking kick the guy off in
some fucking parking lot that they put a
tent over so they could sell
some bud lights with Lyman.
It. Remember those days,
your member member that right.
We get fucking hammered and then the
fuck and the red line would shut down and
we'd have to fucking steal a cat.
Sorry,
I'm pitching the, uh, the
sequel to goodwill hunting.
How soon before they reboot that,
right. I would say goodwill,
this is a leather chair. I'm
not farting profusely here. Um,
what was I gonna say? Yeah, the SQL to
fucking goodwill hunting. All right,
we'll marry the check there.
Minnie driver,
he marries her.
They have four kids now that
divorced because, you know,
just hugging Robin Williams
doesn't erase a childhood.
So eventually his demons,
because he is who he is,
came out the fucking marriage
and now they got four kids.
And uh,
the one that's most like will doesn't
get along with them, you know,
cause they're so alike,
right. A Den. Uh, I dunno.
I Dunno where it, if somehow
this iron man, they're still,
they're actually promote the movie or
fucking one of those fucking God damn.
What is that chicken?
And there's,
there's like no end in sight to
those fucking movies, right? Yeah.
Okay.
It's like become an incestuous now.
Now they like doing like the
oceans 11 of like superhero movies.
Yeah.
He's fucking poor actress man.
You know, back in the day,
used to dream of getting a role of plane
that this play into that now everybody
that just, everybody's selling. If
a dude, I just, if I could just be,
if I could just be a lightening man,
I could get a bungalow in fucking
Oxnard. Um, but who knows.
Congratulations to Liverpool. They
one, I missed the game yesterday.
They want two to one.
I was hoping that one to nothing.
So I could say to nil sound like I know
what I'm talking about. As far as I know,
there's still one point behind the fucking
man city cuts all that Middle Eastern
money. You want your money
clean from a pure nation,
a pure part of the world.
Like the United States of America.
It's right cause we're always
on the right side of the ball.
As is any comedian out
there listening right now.
If you want to get laughs
when you go overseas,
just start reciting our propaganda.
You don't even need a set up or anything
and people just start laughing. Beacons.
Afraid of people. Just stay. Just
laugh. All right, the standings.
What do we got here?
Okay.
Oh,
the first place by two points.
Oh my God, you gotta be shitting. Oh
wait, wait, wait. Before I get excited.
Is it still, is this
the latest one? It is.
Are you fucking kidding me?
What happened?
What happened to man city with
the never ending oil money?
What happened? Ah, the old breakfast
buffet. Gotcha. The Yates came in,
but their big ballet to that big bay cat.
All right, I love it. I love money
against money cause I'm a capitalist.
I want to see how this is going down.
Is there anything better than watching
these giant hardware stores just putting
each other on a business?
I can't get enough of it.
Just fucking throw it down.
Like blood sport on TV be the
ones that shallow the Hamish.
No one was share lab and
this part of the region.
It's part of the world unless
we say shawl. Oh, watch that.
You want to build something?
We rolling off the others.
I'm sorry.
Anyway, supplying a head here. Uh,
this morning after I went to the
gym, did my leg, she yesterday,
my pasty spindly legs that just
never seem to want to get any bigger,
but I have to do them to,
to,
to keep my a sciatic nerve issue at bay
because what happened after years and
years that drive in myself to gigs,
right. Playing every shit
hole from here to fucking uh,
Chilkoot Charlise I did them
all. White privilege, um,
Hashtag not so much.
I hate when white people because they
actually had to work for what they wanted
in life.
Think that they're not privileged.
Okay.
My
Dad didn't have a yacht. Therefore, um,
do you need to look it up?
Doesn't mean you don't have to work.
It just means that no point was your
skin color a detriment. If anything.
It was a positive. Uh, that's not true.
I was one of the people that that
did get put up Canada College.
I like when white people talk about
affirmative action to when like nine black
kids get in and they say that's why they
weren't able to join the other 30,000
white kids at the university. Oh
that's why that, that's what it was.
That's what held you back.
You know,
you couldn't get into the upper
fucking 92% of white people.
You were in the lower 8%.
And now I'm supposed to feel bad for you
snow.
Sorry. Um, anyway,
so I was doing the dishes and I wore a
long sleeve shirt cause it gets a little
cool out here in the
desert in the morning.
So I wore a long sleeve workout shirt
so I didn't want to get any water.
My sleep's fucking gross and be out
the same way. When I put lotion on,
I take my wedding ring off cause I don't
like when it gets underneath the ring,
it fucking grosses me out.
So I take off my shirt and I'm standing
there shirtless watching, um, relaxed.
Ladies,
um,
upstanding shirtless washing dishes.
Um,
the way I wish my wife would.
and it was reminded me of every joke
that I heard a bunch of comics do back in
the day when they were
talking about cops going like,
is there a rule that when you get arrested
you have to not be wearing a shirt
then never wearing a shirt.
And it was fucking true when
it finally dawned on me today,
probably that was because a lot of
them couldn't afford air conditioning,
you know, and God knows, you know,
they want to get a lot of seasons. When
they first did cops, they were like,
well how many AUC can you get five
seasons out of this? It's like, well,
we're mainly going to shoot in Florida
and down south and everybody knows it
gets hot down there harder than June bug.
Fucking a lampoon.
I'm going to fucking July morning.
Um,
so that's my theory with the no shirt
thing. I also think it's a fuck.
It's something that's done by
people that go in and out of jail.
That's just part of the culture is, you
know, you don't wear a shirt to same way.
Like, uh, you know the people that go
to like the fucking Ivy League schools,
you got to wait like the
fucking that do shout fit,
whatever the fuck you call that, the khaki
pants with the fucking loafers. This,
that fucking thing that,
you know,
it's actually one of my favorite looks
when the white person steers into being
white rather than being ashamed of it.
You know what I mean?
Or are trying to put on a blue
collar jacket, you know, cause every,
once every two days you go out,
walk down to the fucking mailbox
to get you fucking mail. You know,
I like people that fucking steer into it.
You know,
what does that look called?
It's like I can't, I, I,
I have like a vague
that,
that thing on Instagram that don't be a
bread. I love the way those kids dress.
Okay.
You know,
the parents had money and now they
know they're getting it and they're not
ashamed of it. They don't have one ounce
of guilt and they're just like, listen,
my daddy polluted all the
rivers and when I take over,
I'm going after the oceans.
You know,
you got to respect it.
It's my goal in that, uh,
there'll be no more polar bears by the
time I'm done running my daddy's company.
I enjoy that. I like that. Just a little
bit of honesty. That's all, you know,
just being who the fuck you are. All
right. Um, I watched the f one yesterday.
Did anybody see the first race of the
year down in Australia? Australian, uh,
Grand Prix, the local
favorite. Daniel Ricardo.
Where's he from? Perth resting
place with a great bond. Scott.
And he's with the Renault team
this year. Who, by the way,
I love the look of their cars, the yellow
and the black. That looks cool as hell.
Granted, I'm a Bruins Fan, so I
dunno. Maybe that's what it is,
but I think those cars are Cooley Shit.
And this poor bastard Danny Ricardo
a the fucking, the race just starts,
he barely goes on the grass in the
front end of his car. Fucking blows up.
Okay,
his front wing hit something
in the whole front of the car,
we're going to get fucking exploded.
So here's my question.
Why do they a bumpy grass? Like that day
that was hit a tree stump or something,
especially right there near the start.
Somebody always goes off the
grass a little bit. Yeah.
Fucked up his car.
And then he was like a layer had to go
in and change the nose up to the front.
Uh, the first lap and then he's down a
lap and then his car just shit the bed and
it's just like he,
he left red bull for this.
I Dunno.
Anyway, so I'm, I'm, I'm basically,
I root for Daniel Ricardo.
Okay.
For some reason I wrote for rough for
Ferrari knowing that they're just not
going to get it done. I root for the
Haas team cause that's the American team.
We did all right yesterday.
Okay.
If you think, you know, one out of
two people finishing as good. Um,
but you know, we did come
in, uh, what's his face?
Magnuson came in sixth place,
eight big points.
Right. And what's his face? It
was the other driver we got there.
What the Hell's his name? Roman
Grogan. Yeah. He didn't finish.
Uh, well where the fuck were
the Ferrari's? The Ferrari's?
We're in fourth and fifth Max
Verstappen who's basically,
I think going to be the next Lewis
Hamilton if he could get a better ride.
Cause for whatever fucking reason,
those red bull cars, you know, they're,
they're taking fuck with the Ferrari's.
But now with the Mercedes,
so one and two is Valtteri
Botox and Lewis Hamilton.
Okay.
I tried, you know, I love
greatness, but I just,
I can't get into the fact how
Lewis Hamilton things fell.
Terry Botox should basically be his gimp,
right?
Baltar's head. This amazing
start. Lewis had the pole,
he fucking blows by him and the first
turn and then he just pulled away for the
rest of the God damn race
Lewis who is having his issues.
And whenever that happens,
he always acts like a baby.
You started bitching that Valtteri
was too far in front of them,
wasn't helping them out. It's like when
the fuck do you want to do that for him?
Ah,
just a fucking, I, I,
you know what, he just,
he reminds me of a couple of comedians
and actors that I've worked with,
like where the whole fucking seen
the whole show. It's about them
all right.
And if overall what happened was good,
but they are part of it wasn't as good
as they like the day day to have a little
fucking hissy fit. Maybe that's why
he's fucking great because he has great,
and I would never say that he wasn't,
but Jesus, he always had like,
I've seen like,
you know,
I've seen Vettel not winning last jam
and Kimmy Reagan and was going to win
something or he was out in front ever
heard him fucking bitching about it.
He just rear ends people in front of them.
Uh,
just buggy. You know, Mercedes
is winning. You're a team.
You took first and second,
you're fine. I know, I know.
The whole deal is the way he's wired.
That's why he's so great.
But it's just like, it's such a
fucking, it's such a chick move.
You know what I mean?
Like,
if you have some shit you have to do
that day is a guy, you go out and do it.
If your wife's got a bunch of shit,
she just be like,
I thought maybe you could come with me.
We could maybe have they a
lunch til he dragging into it.
MMM.
You wouldn't know it, but it's
still loved the guy, you know,
I can never hate on fucking greatness.
The guy is fucking great.
But that part of him,
you know,
I guess we all have that part of ourselves
that maybe we could all work on. Um,
anyways, I'm very excited that it's,
it's, it's back. F one is back, you know,
it was cool. They were like, it's
better. 112 days said, so last race.
And I was thinking like, well, I
haven't drank in 113 days. So freckles.
I took a day off right before
the last race of last year. Um,
I'm almost a third of the way again to
breaking my record of 367 days since I
started drinking.
Okay
man. And what the first 15 years
of my life never had a drop.
I don't see myself beating
that streak anytime soon. Um,
so I think I'm going to try
to go until June of next year.
Okay.
So then I would do a calendar year,
January to December,
and then I would also
do an entire birthday,
like my entire time of being 51 I didn't
have a drop. I think that would be cool.
Then I would go on for like a
fucking year and seven months.
Right.
And at that point I have all
the alcohol out of my house.
And then I think what I do is I, uh, I
don't drink in La. I don't drink at home.
And when I go on the road,
mmm.
One day out of the,
I go on the road,
two weekends a month and
one day out of those things.
So I'd be drinking two times a
month, 24 times a year. Okay.
Whatever the fuck you going to do, I
think that'd be all right. You know,
I got to figure out what the
fuck's gonna open for me.
All my open a fucking crushing it now,
Paul Versey check out the tour dates.
Joe Barden. Nick, we got to
check out puck off. He's got, uh,
the fuck did he just have on there?
Darin McCarty.
He's still in the pilot of the
fucking Nhl awards right now on that.
Eh, the fuck am I going
to have now, you know,
fucking law heads down to San Diego,
crushing it on the sports radio. See,
this is what happens when you
don't bring cupcakes on the road.
They move up into the business.
So I'm just putting it out there.
Are you the funny guy at the office?
Do you think that you'd like
to be a standup comedian? Well,
why didn't you submit your
tape to Bill burg.com?
Maybe you could play some chuckle hut.
Do 15 minutes in front of a bunch of
animals before you bring up the freckled
brick who's closing out the show? Oh, by
the way, how about those brewing? So on?
I'm a, Greg has showed up, right? I missed
the whole game. That's why. Of course,
it was fucking exciting.
I missed the whole God damn game.
I came in right at the end of the streak.
I watched two games where they continued
it and then they lost two in a row and
then I missed the next game and they
went in and over time, Brad Marshawn
fucking in overtime and then he does
the Condom Mcgregor celebration and I
missed the whole goddamn thing.
But you know what I did see,
I did see a maple leafs game.
Who the fuck were they playing?
Somebody who had like a big,
big time lead like a five to two
lead and they came back at one.
Yeah.
I don't know. They were in the
Saint Patrick's Day jerseys.
What has happened to my short term memory?
It's out the window.
Um, I've got to start
playing brain games again.
Who the fuck were they playing anyways?
I,
I uh, Toronto is my, if the
Bruins don't win it this year,
Toronto is my teeth. That's who
the fuck I root for it in the West.
I always root for the Saint Louis Blues.
Those are the two teams that have gone
the longest without winning the fucking
thing. And A, I don't want, Oh,
how much longer do you want their,
their fans to suffer?
Which is why I think it's bullshit.
When that was an Antonio Brown,
whatever his fucking name is,
that wide receiver from, from the
Steelers has a fallen out with his team.
The bills make a deal. They're
like, all right, you're coming in.
And he's just like, yeah, no, I'm
not going there. You guys suck.
Then it goes to the fucking rate is,
it's just like,
so what it bills fans supposed to do?
Okay.
I've never understood that. John
Elway. I'm not playing for the colts.
Well then you're not playing the NFL CFL.
You can't,
right Colby Bryan, I'm not playing
for the Charlotte Hornets. Well,
enjoy Europe.
It's not how it works.
I want to go where the
kids do when immediately,
um,
bunch of fucking babies.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
I guess I understand maybe the quarterback
position just because if he don't
have an offensive line did
she just got to get running,
but you playing fucking basketball,
Jesus Christ,
you can't even touch anybody
anymore. Right. And I can say this,
having not played organized sports
for 40 years, I know what it takes.
Uh, you know what I mean? Is this
is just me bitching as a fan.
I was excited to see the bills get a,
going to an offensive weapon there.
You know, if you want to see a bunch of
grown men cry, you wait till the day,
the fucking bills when,
when the God damn Superbowl.
All right.
Then when the red sox finally won it,
everybody was fucking freaky.
You wait to when the bills went,
cause people are going
to run outside crying.
The tears are gonna freeze on their face
because they live in buffalo and they
just going to hug their neighbor,
right?
And then they're going to fall down and
land on that little heating thing that
heats up there fucking engine in the
morning and it's going to unplug.
And the next morning I remember
rabbi, rabbi, rabbi, rabbi,
rabbi, rabbi, rabbi prep.
It's not going to fucking start.
And then I'm going to give a shit.
They're going to get mad for half a
second and then they go, wait a minute.
Okay.
Wait a minute. They fucking, they
won the super bowl. Now I don't,
I don't give a shit anymore.
Um,
anyway, uh, plowing ahead here.
What else am I going to do
today? I'm going to go get
it. I'm getting three Mris.
I'm finally going to finally see what's
going on with my shoulders and then my
left knee. That's what I'm doing
today. And we'll fix my, uh,
both my shoulders and my knee and then,
uh,
I'll probably have some sort of
cancer from all that radiation. See,
that's how it works. Everybody, you know,
it's one of the reasons
why I love breaking bad is
every time they made a step
forward there, there was always a price
to pay and it, and at best they were even,
but they never really were. They always
sank down a little bit lower. You know,
doesn't make any fucking sense.
Okay.
I'll tell you everybody,
this world,
this world doesn't make
any fucking sense to me.
Hm.
Yeah.
This whole fucking
okay.
Food thing and booze thing. Here's
something. I finally had an epiphany
about being an adult and addiction
and being fat and fucking,
all of this shit that you try to avoid is,
um,
no one ever really tells you
like the,
the level of responsibility of when you
go out on your own just for yourself,
not fuck the whole thing up.
I was sitting there, right?
I'm on the Instagram and one of the
people I follow, he's in his twenties,
right? Eddie's Fellman like
the night out. All right.
His drummer. Okay. And everybody's
drinking. Everybody's dancing a,
it just keeps going and going and going
and going and going until like fucking
four in the morning. And, um,
I understand that you do
that when you're that age,
but there is a part of me thinking like,
what if I didn't do that?
Not like I danced in the street,
but you know what I mean. I,
I puked in the street til like
four in the fucking morning.
What if I didn't do that?
Like,
how many more miles on this engine,
what I have,
you know, cause like right now, I'll tell
you, my drug is eight hours sleep, honey.
MMM.
Okay.
I don't know, just as far as like,
I was really sitting there like,
trying to think how I'm gonna explain
that to my daughter one day. It's like,
all right,
you going off to college now you're
going to have this ridiculous level of
freedom. I remember the first time
when I finally fucking moved out.
Yeah.
I remember I was in New York City.
It was my first night hanging out.
I was hanging out at the comic strip.
Okay.
And
it hit me.
It's like I don't have to fucking
go home until I want to go home.
I don't have to answer to fucking anybody.
And this big grin just broke out
on my face like, Jesus Christ,
this is fucking amazing. Because of
course I was down in like, Jesus Christ,
they moved like two states away.
I don't fucking know anybody.
I'm in a railroad apartment.
You know,
I just talked to Lucian rest
his soul and he's like, yeah,
Guardian, have an ovoid
goes, I have no need, Rio.
Good luck with your dream.
Um,
I remember just sitting
there at that bar and then,
but then the epiphany is
that Jesus Christ, I could
fucking do whatever I want.
I can fucking meet a chick, take a
home. It's just fucking unbelievable.
And fortunately during that time,
everybody that I was hanging out with
was either they didn't drink or they were
already an Aa. And I've
always just been, you know,
I just did what people around with,
nobody around me is drinking.
They want to go on and go to a diner
instead. I would just fucking do that.
So I didn't drink a lot in my twenties,
but somewhere in my thirties it kind
of went off the fucking rails and a,
I wish I could go back a tiff.
I could tell you guys anything yet.
Don't bring the booze into the house.
Okay.
Have they just like literally,
why would you bake cookies and cake
and potato chip into your house?
You're going to become a fat fuck.
You bring booze in the house.
She's going to become a drunk.
I'm not saying an alkie,
but it'll just be something
that you just fucking dope.
Do you like smoking a cigar?
Don't buy a humidor.
Keep it at,
don't bring the devil India House.
Keep 'em down the fucking street.
You get any out to dealers because you'll
sit there for 10 minutes being like,
I fuck man, I'd love a God damned cigar
or I'd love to go get a drink. And then,
but then you sitting there
and I got fucking get dressed.
I got to get in the car to, you
know, fuck this. I'll just, you know,
I'll just sit here and hang out.
But the, the one thing I have,
this really fascinates
me is now that I don't,
um,
I'm really not doing anything is uh,
getting used to just being sober.
And I don't just mean, you know, booze.
I mean then also combining that with
trying to eat right because it's like at
the end of the night,
like I'm just used to being ramped up,
having a couple of pops and then when
you quit Bosun then that becomes like
food. Like eat something sugary or
read something salty and you know,
Leno just fucking get the rpms
going in your body. And then we're,
the reality is your body
doesn't want to do that.
It just wants to be fucking idling,
chilling out,
saving it's stuff for when he
got to run from an earthquake,
a fire or some guy with an ax essentially.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
I feel like I need to take, uh, you know,
that shit that you put in your
gas tank to clean out your engine,
but then you get nervous.
Am I going to move the clots around?
Okay.
I feel like I got to
fucking do that, man. Um,
so now my big thing is like,
I've,
I've been cooking at home and last night
I asked for the first time in forever,
I made like a full meal,
like two sides and uh,
and I, it'll look a little stink.
So I made this little stake.
I had some steamed Broccoli and then,
uh,
I had the potatoes, right? Garlic
was a little bit of Rosemary,
a little bit of salt and pepper
and some butter. Oh my God,
they were fucking delicious.
That was basically,
that was the highlight of my night
was those mashed potatoes. Um,
but, uh, I'm going to fucking,
I'm trying to revamp my
whole lifestyle here.
Um, so when I returned to drinking,
which I will at some point,
I just want to make sure
that I do it in a, uh,
put like the way I drink soda or pap
few people in the Midwest, like a cage.
Like if I have like a bomb out, it's
usually back east. If I'm having a pizza,
then I would always get a coke.
And even then I can never really fuck.
I could never really finish it.
If I'm just having a bad meal,
I'll have like a coke or something like
that. If I could just do that with booze,
you know, those fucking people, they
can just have a glass of wine. Ooh. Mm.
That was delicious. That
complemented my meal. Right.
They don't sit there like a pirate
and fucking bite the cork off it.
Um, anyway, I did a, uh,
I did a Gig at the American legion.
I got to open for Ron White.
I worked with Joe de Rosa and,
um, it's the other guy, Alex.
I didn't get his last name.
He's fucking hilarious.
And A and John Sites,
we had a fucking great time and I'm
okay
afterwards.
You know,
we smoke some cigars and stuff and
there was a couple of buddies of mine,
they showed up and one of them showed up.
He bought a fucking,
one of those new Indian motorcycles.
The one that looks like the
Harley road king. Ah, fuck dude.
Okay.
I would love one of those two tone.
He had black with the green man.
That thing was fucking sick.
And uh,
and all those guys on those big bites,
they always go,
it's like riding a Cadillac.
You know, it's getting,
it's got the three lights
people can see. Ah, um,
ah man,
that's,
that's one of those fucking that
owner remain the dad fantasy.
It's like if I didn't have a kid,
if I didn't,
if I wasn't living for somebody else,
Thou my God,
I would fucking get one of those. I
would take it out Sunday mornings. Right.
It's drive down the fucking street.
I freckled arms up, you know,
feeling like I'm in a motorcycle gang
when I really never killed anybody.
Pay My taxes quarterly. I blocked that
part out. Right. Drive down the street.
Um, I would fucking love one of those.
I love those boots as a bikes. I love,
I love those big ones with the, uh, the
white wall tires and shit like that.
Like I love a Harley rode
king without the bags on it.
I just think that that is just one of the
fucking coolest silken bikes ever. Um,
who knows.
Okay.
My daughter graduates high school,
goes off to college.
Maybe I'll do it then I'd
be like my late sixties,
I'll get one of those.
That's right around the time when you get
that three wheeler fucking motorcycle,
you know,
um,
which I would think in a lot of ways it
could be a little bit more dangerous for
all of a sudden you kind of had to
like, I dunno, like how does that work?
If somebody cuts out in front of
you and you got to lay it down,
you can't lay it down.
What do you do?
Um, you just fucking t bone the
guy and go flying over the fucking,
I don't know.
There's gotta be some sort of Robo
cop type thing that they can put on.
Can you buy one of those moto GP suits
with like the fucking airbag in it and
shit. They don't have an air bag for your
head. That's the problem. Wait a second.
Moto g p writing suit for sale.
It'll be like five grand if they do.
Well there's one for $478
so you know that's not it.
I appreciate it.
Put Air bag in there
with airbag and then you
get to like that would,
the thing is like that's
like hooked onto the bike.
Come on you fucking cunts.
Yeah.
Shop race, shop race suits
with airbags. All right.
Amazon.
There's one for 1000 bucks.
There's one for fourth 1500 bucks.
All right, that sounds about right.
You know the moto GP ones,
if you actually got one of those it's
like fucking three grand but is a thing.
You can have one of those and it's
not going to help you if someone,
an SUV runs you over.
Yeah, and another life.
I would have had kids younger and then
I would have lived in the middle of
nowhere and I would've had one. Oh,
well. Um, speaking of motorcycles,
motorcycle, uh, Japanese
and Italian motorcycles.
I don't have any advertising this week.
All right.
Japanese and Italian motorcycles.
Hey Bill,
on your Ma match 14th podcasts.
You wondered why Japanese and Italian
companies make better motorcycles.
That's not what,
all right.
I had a little glitch there and ran
out of batteries, ran out of batteries.
Um,
getting back to what I was saying,
I didn't say that you guys
make better motorcycles.
He just make the fast ones.
Like why don't mean,
why hasn't Honda India or somebody
like that and make a fast one? Um,
one explanation I've heard they're
probably better, but as an American,
I can't fucking say that.
One explanation I heard is that after
World War Two engineers and designers for
the access military
industry industrial complex,
we're forced to find civilian and non
military work. Some of the brightest,
smartest engineers in those
countries ended up in automotive,
motorcycles and electronics,
Honda, Yamaha, Sony, Ferrari,
Lamborghini,
Ducati,
or to caddy as they say
in England in particular,
or at least the announcer
does in particular,
aeronautical engineers who
had designed a fighter planes,
found success applying their knowledge
to motorcycle chassies designed because
many of the forces acting on a plane's
fuselage is similar to the forces on a
motorcycle leaned over, going
through a turn. That's fascinating.
Also because of rationing in the years
following World War II engineer's and
former access countries had to figure
out how to design and manufacturer with
less raw material like steel or aluminum.
You can see how efficient the engineered
German Italian and Japanese engines are
compared to a chunky Harley
Davidson motorcycle. Uh,
just post ride chat I've
heard over the years.
But I thought you might
find an interesting,
thanks for making me laugh and making
your podcast that it's really interesting.
Something else.
Um,
is that just the sheer amount
of space that we have over here,
you know,
that we're not driving down these little
streets that used to ride a fucking
horse and buggy around in that
everything needs to be really, the cars.
Motorcycles got to be quick and nimble
and all of that. You could just fucking,
you know, if you look at our
cars, it's the same thing.
It's all about zero to 60 in a straight
line because for the most part there's
not a lot of turns and shit, you
know, that we're going to be taking.
So I think part of it is also that, but
I really find that interesting that um,
okay, just through, you know,
a loss comes a wind like that,
that's usually what happens there.
Reminds me, I was watching, um,
uh,
that Joe Rogan podcast with Mike Tyson
and he was alluding to the fact and a lot
of boxes have that. Like, you know,
boxing is basically that.
There's never been like a rich kid that
I can think of that just, you know,
came from a great background
and everything just goes
in. And does that, like,
it's,
it's for somebody that just came from
nothing and you could literally literally
fighting your way out of it. Um,
that would be fucking hilarious.
So if one of those don't be a
Brad kids actually came, you know,
one of those kids that accidentally kills
his girlfriend while having rough sex.
Remember those fucking billionaire boy
club fucking lunatics from the 80s. Uh,
if one of him,
he came in and if he just steered
into it like a great wrestling heel,
like when he did his interviews,
he had his boat shoes with
no socks on and khaki pants
and he's just in his old thing is even
though we came up with all that money and
shit, he's just like a
complete fucking sociopath
and then goes in and like his nickname
should just be staring into all of that
shit.
Like what the fuck would be be like,
uh, Brad, the trust fund
kid, you know, fucking
van something or other as always the
fucking rich white people names. Right.
I miss that. I miss the Robert Baron
being famous. You know, I should,
I'd missed it the first time,
but like JP Morgan, wow.
Andrew Carnegie,
not man and nobody else then
just all became a corporation.
I think that that's why they did it.
They became a corporation. So then they,
their names wouldn't be out there.
So now it's like,
can you believe what Alberta ed raw
dig you believe? What would a Monsanto,
you don't have one fucking name,
you know,
just as far as bar room chatter goes.
Sure.
If he actually took the time
to care enough to research it.
Didn't you know a name?
All right.
I think I was kind of shitting on myself
by the end there. Um, all right. Okay.
What else do we got here?
Marginal tax rate. Hey Bill,
I'm listening to a recent podcast where
you talk about [inaudible] plan to tax
people at a higher rate.
Uh,
the marginal tax rate kicks in after
someone earns their first $10 million.
After that,
the income is taxed at 70%.
That fuck that.
Fuck that.
Okay.
That doesn't touch people who create
startups yet does when they turn around
sell it for fucking
tens of millions of dollars.
Of course it does.
Yeah.
Most comedians don't make
anything close to that.
You don't even know what comedians make.
That's not fucking true.
Comedians are crushing it right now.
And secondly,
what I fucking hate about all of this
shit is everybody's going to ignore the
reason why we're broke.
We're broke because we're fighting this
never ending fucking war that is lining
the pockets of about four and a half
a dozen to a dozen corporations,
and it's completely bankrupted
this fucking country.
So rather than take those people to task,
who pay all the fucking politicians,
now you're going to go after
regular fucking citizens
and we're going to have to
pay the tab. Go Fuck Yourself, dude.
70% tax on anything is fucking criminal.
Criminal,
okay
to take more than half
somebody is doing that work.
You don't get more than half of that.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Those politicians need to grow a fucking
Dick and some fucking balls and stand
up to those corporations that they're
fucking blowing. That's the solution.
Fucking God damn fucking people who
sit there and they demonize anybody.
Any individual that went out and
went after a dream and made it,
and then they have to turn around
and subsidize your fucking life.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You really want to take down the rich.
Go after these fucking corporations
that have all their money in offshore
fucking accounts. Kick him out of the
fucking country and stop buying this shit.
Don't fucking punish some person because
they started dollar shave club and
they're fucking dormitory. Now all of a
sudden they got to give 70% of it away.
You know what you sound like?
You sound like somebody who's never
going to make $10 million in their life.
Oh my God. That drives me up the
fucking wall, and that's the genius.
Once again of corporations, it's,
there's no name, there's no face to it,
but she could do it with individuals,
so now they're going to get punished.
Anyway, so let me finish
this. After the income,
it's tax 70% that doesn't talk to
people could create it. Startups.
That's just a statement that
you pulled out of your ass.
Most comedians don't make anything close
to that that's pulled out of your ass
that's pulled out of your reps.
I've seen like the top fucking, um,
earning comedians that Forbes fucking
lists. They're all over 10 million.
Some of them making $20 million.
They supposed to get 70%
of over 10 million away.
Okay.
Anyways,
uh,
the most skilled brain
surgeons don't make that much.
Yeah.
The people making more than 10 million
a year are close with extremely high
concentrations of wealth. No,
they're not. This is this what,
this is what you're doing,
dude.
What's you're doing is you're creating
this cartoon character of a rich person
the same way female comics created a
cartoon character of a white male comedian
where he just goes down to the
club and the club are, and it goes,
what are your dreams?
How many doors can I open for you?
Nobody wants to see that it's
fucking work. I can't even,
I can't even read the fucking rest of
this. That's like that person going,
somebody who makes $10 million a year.
It doesn't work any harder than someone
who makes $20,000 a year. I was like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Okay.
If you work for yourself, I don't
care what the fuck you make a year.
It never rents. It's,
it's seven days a week,
three 65 you're working
your fucking ass off.
Yeah.
Anyways, collecting it at a rate
that is unnecessary for on human,
any human on earth.
Being able to start from nothing is
what Amerit makes America great. Yeah.
You're going to Yank all
these people back down again.
Those people also will make that
they create a bunch of fucking jobs.
There's a way to run your
country that your company, right.
Anyway,
so this is being able to start from
nothing is what makes America great and if
anything, a higher tax rate enables
more Americans to follow their dreams.
That is complete bullshit because what
you're going to do is just yank your
fellow fucking countrymen down
to the ground. None of this shit.
You're not going to get to go out to
these fucking corporations there and all
these super rich people,
their money's already out of the country.
They got it running through
fucking 20 different islands.
Yeah,
and there's 20 different fucking
mountains are red tape that the IRS is not
going to take their time to go through
and that's why they're going to go after
just regular fucking people because we're
standing here with that fucking pants
down.
Okay.
Allowing people to hoard massive amounts
of wealth only shrinks the middle class
creating larger conglomerates and pushes
us further towards a horrible dystopia
where everything is commercialized.
Well, first of all, dude,
you're about 40 fucking years too
late at that party, all right? It all,
you're all, you're all these
fucking tax things are going to do.
They're not going to fuck
with any corporation.
They fucking brush the IRS off their
shoulder like it's a fucking net.
All you're gonna do is you're
going to go after new money.
Somebody went out and started something.
Who the fuck are you to say how much
money anybody can fucking make because you
don't have an idea that will
enable you to make $10 million.
Somebody has to fucking subsidize your
life and you're going to ignore the
fucking elephant in the room and you're
just going to go after the fucking
individual. Go Fuck
Yourself. Go Fuck Yourself.
Okay?
I didn't want to fucking hear this.
This is this fucking bullshit that dead
fucking chick is talking about there
that everybody's all high and mighty on.
She's talking about individuals.
She's not going to go out
after the cold corporations.
They're going to pay her fucking bank
account that she's going to go out and
give speeches to after she's
done with her political career,
to the two to 300 fucking grand a night,
just like the fucking Obama's,
but everybody's going to sit there and
act like it's only the bushes in the
trumps.
The fucking fucking,
Obama's just like the Clintons are lining
their pockets with that same fucking
corporate money that is never going
to be fucked with and they just,
they're going to go to stand up
comics people that start apps,
people who start dollar shave club,
that who the,
that's who the fuck is
going to get yanked down.
And you sat there and you, and ever
we've all sat back, support the troops,
support the troops and he can't
fucking speak out against the war.
And you literally watched them
bankrupt his fucking country.
And every year in August, we're
like, we don't have any more money.
We don't have any money.
What's the solution? Do we
go after the fucking banks?
Do we go after the corporations?
No,
we just raised the level of debt that
this country is going to accept and now
we're going to turn around and we're
going to make sure that no, no individual,
okay,
who doesn't fucking pour
water in the fucking, uh, uh,
rivers and pour water,
poor fucking the chemicals in the
Damn rivers and all that shit.
Just let all of those fucking people,
all of those cons,
who fucking polluted your fucking God
damn food supply to the point you got
girls getting their fucking periods at
nine years old and a kid could grow a
fucking full beard by the time
he's 10 ignore all of that shit
and just sit there and be like, I don't
think you need to make $10 million.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You know what buddy?
I hope you make $10 million and I hope
you get to keep more than God damn
fucking 30% of it because you earned it.
You should have to pay
cause you fucking cause.
So what could you earn
too much fucking money.
Listen,
I've got to tell you something right now.
If these corporations were
paying their fair fucking share,
I wouldn't have a problem
with this and you,
if you wanted to cap it at $10 million,
fine,
but that's not what the
fuck you going to do.
Okay.
All right.
I got heated there.
Yeah.
Fucking God damn stupid ass
fucking morons out there
okay
with you. Yeah. Why don't you
read up on what the fuck it takes.
Okay.
What are you read up on what it takes to
fucking go from not having anything to
fucking get in there?
Why don't you actually figure out how
hard you have to fucking work to even get
anywhere close to half
of that fucking money.
Okay.
How fucking strong you
have to be mentally.
How much bullshit you have to get put
through as you fucking watching other
people around you that you started out
with, watching them slowly go crazy,
watching them kill themselves and
all of this other fucking shit,
and then turn a complete blind eye to
fucking banks and corporations and all of
these fucking assholes. Let,
yeah, let's go off to people
making months. Yeah. Yeah.
Fucking nationwide drug epidemic.
Let's just completely ignore all the
fucking pharmaceutical companies.
That's fine. That's fine.
Let's just go after Joe blow.
Who fucking worked his fucking balls off?
Yeah.
You know
who the fuck are you to say?
What the fuck?
Just a certain segment of people are
going to fucking make and you're going to
ignore all those goddamn corporations
and don't even fucking tell me to Ho go
after them to how they run the fuck they
run. All of these fucking politicians,
every one of them's on their
fucking knees blowing them.
And occasionally when you got a guy like
Bernie Sanders who actually wants to
stand up to those cons,
what do they do?
They fucking box him out and to
give him no coverage whatsoever.
Now what are they? Do they go with the
fucking made man? The Hillary Clinton,
right?
And then she loses to this orange headed
Khan and now we're dealing with this
shit.
Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ.
All right,
mother law was some messed up
passive aggressive behavior.
I have to end this podcast
soon cause I gotta go fucking,
Oh my God.
Nobody who's making,
who's not making $10 million
should fucking be telling
somebody what they should
be. Fine. Am I saying what
the fuck you should be paying?
I want to hear what's your fucking ideas?
Then I'm going to bet that if
I ever get over 10 million,
I'm going to be fucking subsidizing
what's, you can sit on your
fucking ass and not do anything.
And if a fucking nine to five job and
it'll be over right at fucking five
o'clock on Friday,
you could do whatever the fuck you want
for the rest of your fucking weekend.
Well,
what poor people who fucking are running
companies got to figure out all through
the weekend how to keep that thing afloat
so you still have your fucking job.
Then on top of that,
they supposed to give 70% of their
money over 10 million a year.
She can get another fucking beanbag chair.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Unbelievable. Yeah, we
haven't, we still haven't.
We shown that just giving people
fucking money doesn't do anything.
Okay.
There really is that fantasy that,
you know,
if you give people fucking opportunity,
uh,
you know they're going to make
something of themselves not true.
Yeah.
That's only half the recipe. That's
like, if you get a bag of sugar,
you can make a pie. No, you
can't. You need fucking eggs, Ede.
All kinds of other fucking shit.
Somebody has to have the drive,
they have the vision and
they gotta be strong enough.
Okay.
There when they keep getting a dick knock
in the dark to keep fucking getting up
okay
and staying positive and not letting
his fucking business each you up.
I had a fucking text from a buddy of
mine last night, I couldn't believe,
I haven't talked to him about
how fucking negative be got.
And I'm trying to find a nice way to say,
dude,
don't let this business get to you.
Don't let them put the fucking pilot
light out because when they do,
you're fucking done.
All right.
I never had to have that fucking talk
when I was unloading trucks working in a
warehouse.
I Dunno.
Listen,
I am all for
fucking pay and taxes
and all of that shit.
If they would actually spend it on
fucking the public schools, if they would,
if they would actually spending on trying
to give people tax breaks to fucking
keep industry in this goddamn
country and they haven't,
everybody who's thought about themselves
and they've sent the thing out the
fucking window.
So now what's going to happen is
you're going to start going after the
individual and somehow demonize somebody
that actually went after dream and is
corrupted.
His function country is actually got,
you're not going to fucking Yankees
fucking pants down the fuck outta here.
Fucking bullshit.
I think for you to make a statement
like that, at some point your life,
you should, you should actually have
made over $10 million a fucking year.
So maybe you'd have a
little bit of empathy.
You could actually speak with some sort
of fucking knowledge instead of sitting
there playing the God damn victim.
All right.
If you want to start a fucking revolution
to go off to banks and corporations,
I'm fucking all for it.
If you want to start yanking other fucking
knew your own fellow countrymen have
done nothing wrong down by their fucking
ankles because they had the balls to go
after something,
it fucking actually become successful.
And then you're, you're gonna decide
how successful they need to be
because these people are fucking honest
enough to actually report their goddamn
income. They, meanwhile,
you got the fucking country wants the
Goddamn Corporation after it's gone
through 20 fucking Goddamn islands is
now getting a loan from the last fucking
island I interest free
tax free fucking loan.
His money comes back to them in the form
of a fucking loan and then that Phantom
fucking corporation forgives the
loan and the guys pay in 0% taxes.
Okay,
how about that buddy?
How about that? Yeah.
Well let's ignore corporations that
keep us in wars that bleed this country,
die dry, and let's go after
the dollar shave club guy.
There you go. There you go.
Let's go after the guys who started
barstool sports. Yes, they're the,
they're the fucking problem motivated
fucking people who started from nothing
and in it hit the mother load.
I Dunno.
Jesus Christ. That was fucking 10
minutes of my life. I'll never get back.
All right. Mother in law was some messed
up, passive aggressive behavior there.
Bill,
my boyfriend's mother is probably the
most passive aggressive piece of shit you
ever met in your life, by the way.
I still have to talk about this.
The fucking level of
money that I'm making.
I'm lucky if I get to keep a third of it
in on paper.
I'm not paying 70% tag.
You wait til that fucking thing kicks in
and if you think they're going to stop
at 10 million and then it's
going to be well at 5 million,
should they pay this at 1 million?
Shouldn't they pay this?
Any check that I get? Any fucking
check that I get. I just, I just,
I take 70% already and throw it out
the fucking window with commissions,
expenses and then the taxes that I pay.
That's why people fucking go broke.
They go out and they get $1 million
and they think they have $1 million.
It's like you don't,
you have about 375 grand if you're lucky.
That's what $1 million is before you're
going to implement this bullshit.
Yeah.
Kind of a fucking American to fucking
it is for pulling down another
regular guy. Who was you? Yeah.
Why not get inspired by that person?
No.
You should give some year
money that you made back to me.
Fucking go fuck yourself.
Oh my God.
Why doesn't it everybody
get to play it down?
A Bennett fell football just because
their NFL dream didn't make it right.
Why don't you just let them
do that? Uh, dear bill,
my boyfriend's mother is probably the
most passive aggressive piece of shit you
ever met in your life.
She's still relatively young in her
early fifties and acts like a college kid
around her friends.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
It's probably more annoying than the
last 12 minutes of this podcast. Uh,
you just know that she was a sorority
bullied when she was younger and now she
treats her family very
passive aggressively.
Okay.
Oh Wow. For example, when she came
over for dinner to our house recently.
Okay.
We asked if she could remove her shoes
as we don't appreciate the filth from the
street infecting our floors.
This slide at her from the get go
and then she went to the bathroom and
deliberately left skid marks on the toilet
and came out on that announcing to the
room that we should clean it regularly to
prevent that from happening.
Oh my God.
I know that sounds crazy,
but this is the same person who also
made a big deal about how somebody should
get tested for an STD because my,
oh,
saying how I should get
tested for an STD because,
okay.
My last boyfriend had
an uncircumcised penis.
Please let me know what you would do to
put her in her place once and for all.
MMM.
Oh, this is a tough one. This is
family. A family, the family, Becky's,
um,
mother-in-law with messed up
passive aggressive behavior,
but you're calling it your boyfriend.
Yeah.
You got to nip this in the bud
before you even fuck or the bud,
whatever the fuck you say.
Nip in the bud before, uh,
before this goes any fucking further.
MMM.
You don't want to marry into that.
And if you do marry into it,
you got to set up boundaries.
MMM.
Uh, here's the deal. I would just, uh,
I would say something to your boyfriend
and what I would do.
Yeah.
Uh, that's probably not going to
work. You know what I would do?
I would just say I don't
appreciate that comment.
And if you have to have a fight with her,
I have a fight with her and just say,
listen to your coming over my house and
these are my rules. If you don't like it,
don't come over here.
And if she has a fucking problem with
that and your boyfriend is a problem with
that, fuck the both of
them. Fuck the both of them.
Yeah.
All right.
There's no reason for you to be walking
around on egg shells where you live.
Fuck this fucking person.
And you'll basically show your future
mother in law who you are and your
boyfriend,
who you are and you know, whoever has a
problem with it and go fuck themselves.
You can come over and then leave skid
marks in my toilet and say somebody should
clean that.
You should have grabbed her by the back
of her fucking neck and the seat of her
pants and thrown her out bounces style.
Okay.
Right out of your fucking house.
The fuck out of my house.
Okay.
Clean up my shit.
Get the fuck out of my house.
That's an easy one.
That's as easy as the $10 million a year
thing there. Uh, I, I'm open to
it too. It's hilarious of sale.
I'm open to more debate on that 70.
I'll talk to somebody who will actually
talk about the corporations and banks.
If you want to talk about that first
and what you plan to do with them,
then I will listen to your fucking over
$10 million and I don't make anywhere
near that.
But like I plan to,
I'm building a company,
I plan on that and I don't plan
on fucking working my ass off.
So then I could just go give it to a
bunch of corrupt cops who aren't going to
give it to you.
They're not going to give it to you.
They're going to give it in the
form of contracts to peak to people.
At big construction companies to build
more luxury, high rise apartments.
They're going to give them the kickback
fucking money and they're gonna charge
way more money for the fucking materials.
All of that fucking shit.
Government fucking jobs,
building roads and all of that.
That score is going to go,
it's not going to go back to the kids.
It's not going to go back to the
schools and it's not going to go to you.
It isn't. It never does because
they're all fucking corrupt.
So if you want to talk about how to
somehow pay politicians more money so they
don't, so they have
fuck you money. So they,
they don't have to fucking sit there
and suck the dicks of these corporations
and these bags.
Then maybe we could try to fucking
have as honest accompanies you a
country as you could possibly have,
which is impossible because
people shit on socialism.
They shit on communism is shit
on capitalism. None of them work.
None of them work because human
beings are inherently flood. Alright,
so there you go. That's my uninformed
bullshit for the fucking day.
God bless all of you. I got some
shit to do. I know the podcast,
it was a little bit short,
but you're probably sick of me after I
was on my tree stump there for fucking 12
minutes. All right. God bless all of you.
I hope your dreams come true and I hope
when you go out and you make the money
that you earned, some cut doesn't
come in and take 70% of it. All right?
See you Thursday.